mark it is so lovely to be here with you
today thanks for joining me yeah thanks
for having me of course so let's start
off tell me about exactly what goalt
does so goalt is a tech enabled uh
sustainably driven end to-end logistics
company which is a bit of a mouthful
which basically means that we take
product into our warehouses we move it
across our Network and we get it to
Shoppers interesting so who's your
Target customer so we we are
increasingly working with Enterprise
customers so mostly Fortune 500 to
intelligently distribute their inventory
manage their middle Mile and their last
mile delivery and how did you get the
idea for this tell me about the founding
story here yeah so this is an
interesting one where it's actually
nothing to do with what we do today so
we've kind of stumbled into what we are
now so so bear with me uh the business
started as a company called second
closet we would pick up store and return
people's stuff it was a valley storage
company so we were essentially a 3pl for
your your things um we launched into the
international student Market where we
would store international student stuff
over the summer bring it back to them in
September and kind of rinse and repeat
um and we launched that business by
basically breaking into dorm room
buildings and slipping business cards
under dorm room doors and putting flyers
in front of urals and inside of bathroom
stalls I love it and so with 500 bucks
we built a 20K a month business in two
weeks and we said okay well we should
probably quit the jobs that we haven't
started yet and and do this full-time
that's really cool so then how did you
take it then from dorm room to being an
actual company yeah yeah that for for
sure and that's that's something that
we're we're still pinching ourselves on
but when we started it was uh know five
of us in the business uh scaling I think
in our first year we ended with 12
people in 2017 um now we're well over a
thousand um and what we found was that
our best users were actually businesses
people that would store their stuff
whether it was Chief brand officers at
clothing companies or uh Community
managers at co-working spaces they would
use us now to like store their business
stuff and move around for Business
Solutions uh and then so we said why
don't we just build software and
solutions for you specifically and
that's sort of when the business took
off as more of a traditional 3pl uh that
we a ton of tech and Innovation around
cool so now how did you know parents you
know friends people in your life react
when you said you know right out of
college you're going to just start your
own company was there any any doubts or
was it hard yeah you know I had
distinctly two groups of friends that
had two distinct uh opinions okay and so
um my brother and I were on our own
since I was 17 so we're totally
financially independent we were just
living together and we had moved out so
we were uh it was basically do or die
and I was was in the mindset of getting
like a typical corporate job and having
like a stable stable life so when I was
recruited into management consulting and
had this you know pretty amazing salary
coming out of University I was like okay
well our life is now set and we can kind
of breathe a sigh relief um so when I
told my friends that I was quitting the
job that I didn't start yet to do this
and make basically nothing and eat ramen
noodles all day uh there were some
people looked at me weird and others
were like yeah this is totally what you
should be doing and um I convinced my
co-founder hindrik to to start with me
and quit his job which was even better
than mine and we are now uh building
this this incredible business amazing
talk to me about your fundraising
Journey yeah and how that's been for you
so I've never been a great fundraiser uh
I've had a couple other other businesses
that I probably should have raised money
for that had really good steam but I
just operated them on a cash flow
positive basis and took the money as I
said like we were totally on our own so
and used that to pay through school uh
but we've been very fortunate I met uh
an angel investor that really believed
in what we were doing and believed in us
as as human beings and we were able to
raise a 500K seed round in 2017 which
then went to a $2 million round a $10
million round a 20 110 uh 75 so all told
we've raised a little over 175 million
uh to date that's incredible and what
has fundraising afforded you and your
company it's afforded you to take
experiments it's it's afforded us to
take experiments uh at varying degrees
of return Horizon so when we think about
making long-term bets you know you can
have this you know we're on this e
transition and we really believe the
future of logistics is sustainable and
so we're investing tens of millions of
dollars into electric uh sustainability
like infrastructure so charging networks
Vehicles Etc so that's something that's
like a mid to long-term return that we
still do today but there's other things
like R&D and software development and
product that we we make a lot of bets on
as well that's one thing I want to touch
on was sustainability because the thing
I liked about your company so much is
that that's so core to what you do can
you explain that a little bit more and
any goals you have for for climate
change or sustainability or ways to help
yeah we we want to be uh known as the
business that prove that you can run a
sustainable last mile delivery and we
don't get fuss that others are
attempting the same thing in fact we
offer our insights up to Partners and
competitors in the industry all the time
um because it's not a you know win or
take all market and the more of Us come
together to collaborate the more we can
actually innovate at a faster pace and
so we really believe that you know come
one come all so I talk to competitors
all the time about their sustainability
journey and how they should think about
it uh and share kind of trials and
tribulations that we've gone through and
what we want to do is Electrify as much
of our last mile delivery as possible so
we've recently transitioned to be an
asset light business where we are
layering our software over other Fleet
operators and Logistics entrepreneurs to
expand our first party Network that we
have control over and then we're going
to help them Electrify as well and so uh
ultimately the goal is to do 100% of our
Zone one zone two delivery on an EV
vehicle wow where are you right now in
that goal so the curve so we have a
truck Division and we have a parcel
division so truck think like you know
two people in a truck delivering like a
sofa and think parcel delivering like a
poly bag of apparel okay um on the The
Apparel side of things and the small
pack uh over half of our deliveries are
done on an EV today um and almost a
third of our deliverers are done on a
truck but by the end of this year um
those numbers will be over 90% amazing
and that's interesting that you say that
you actually talk to your competitor and
and collaborate cuz my next question was
going to be who are your competitors and
then if you're so open with them how are
you setting yourself apart and and you
know setting yourself up to succeed yeah
a lot of our competitors are half a
century old plus so these are businesses
that are really stuck in their ways and
when HRI and I started the business we
always used to look at these companies
and say well why do they always just
like resort to how they've always done
things and now that we are running our
business I think we understand how
difficult it is to inspire change in a
business because it it has to come from
within it has to be cultural change and
so I think we've done a great job at go
bolt to set a culture of innovation and
trying new things and not always having
to be right um and so with our
competitors we know that our culture is
really a huge differentiator the spirit
of the business and how we're going
about affecting change I think is is
different and we don't think that's
easily replicable um maybe that's naive
but we we believe it um and at least
that's what we tell ourselves so um
we're pretty proud of what we're doing
and when we talk to competitors we're
just sharing the Practical journey of
what we're doing and and practical
advice of how they can think about their
electrification Journey differently
interesting so talk to me about the
scale of your company can you tell me
about your your Revenue how many
customers you have anything like that
yeah so so the business is um just over
seven years old uh we are uh over a
thousand people strong and Counting um
we do nine figures plus a revenue
annually and and that's gred a pretty
pretty rapid clip and we're really
excited uh about what the future holds
for us excellent what would you say is
the most challenging part of running
your company the most challenging part
this is a question I get asked all the
time and my answer probably changes
because it's different by the by the
quarter uh I would say right now it's
just driving like a ton of alignment as
we're growing at this like hypers scale
at a already pretty large scale and so
most of what my job is now is
communicating like our mission and
values and how that should affect our
decision- making which sounds super
fluffy but it actually is a massive
amount of time spent and effort because
it's it's really mentally taxing to
manage different departments against one
goal and making sure that everyone
understands how it all interconnects is
there ever a World in which you would
consider selling your company is that
the goal and if so what would it take
we're very Mission driven right now and
we're having a ton of fun doing it so I
I think we would need to find a partner
that would help us accelerate what we're
already doing and we we'd want to make
sure that whatever uh wherever we land
and whatever we do whether it's us
running the business for the next 20
years or us finding a partner that can
help us accelerate that it's it's going
to be Mission driven and it allows us to
do what we're doing uh better and faster
excellent is there anything that you
would tell your younger self the day
before you launched your company that
you wish you knew now that's also a good
question it's one I get asked a lot I
think uh and I don't have a great answer
for it because I think uh I I believe in
the butterfly effect I think everything
that's happened so far has happened for
a reason and it's taught us uh it's
taught us and galvanized Us in the way
that it it has and and we're we're
really proud of where we are today um
what I would probably say is uh be
comfortable navigating through the
unknown I think whenever we're faced
with a challenge or an opportunity um
folks that are on the team that are
super seasoned are evaluating different
paths based on their experience but I
think one thing with Founders is that
you have to really trust your gut and
sometimes when folks have experience
counterintuitively it actually is advice
against what your gut feeling is and
what I found is that nine times out of
10 we always go back to what the gut
feeli told us to do and so I would say
trust your get a little bit more and be
more bold in believing in that even if
there's a ton of really experienced
really smart people telling you
otherwise uh you know your business best
and you'll have the most context now
speaking of experience I know a lot of
under 30 community members tell me that
um they feel a lot of impostor syndrome
because they're they're so young and
they're young Founders and it's hard to
you know speak up in a room of older
more experienced people do you ever feel
like that and how do you combat that if
so I I have not felt it yet and I think
part of the reason is as HRI and I have
built this business we've always been
very heads down so we've never used
anyone else's yard stick to measure our
success we've never looked at
competitors to see how they're thinking
about what we're doing we've always been
like very driven to serve our customer
and so long as our customer told us that
we were doing a good job we would feel
like we're doing a good job and that's
all that really matters at the end of
the day your age you could be 90 you
could be 12 it it doesn't really matter
just as long as you're driving the right
outcomes and so I think our yard stick
is what does our customer tell us and
what does the Shopper tell us and if
they're telling us that we're doing a
good job irrespective of our age
then uh we think that we have the right
to be doing what we're doing so Mark you
said before that you were on kind of the
precipice of of do you take the the leap
into entrepreneurship or you know do you
go into the stable job for you when did
you know like the risk was worth the
reward and what advice would you have
for for people who are kind of in
between both of those worlds right now
it's a great question and I I think back
to like two distinct conversations that
we had at the time one was with uh our
angel investor that really believed in
us and seated the business business and
he said that Mark you can always go back
to this manag consulting job HRA can
always go back into product management
those jobs will be there waiting for
people like you and you should just feel
comfortable taking this Le I actually
was not nervous about that at all what I
was more nervous about was talking to my
managing director at the consulting
company saying hey I know I'm supposed
to start in two weeks however I'm trying
to give you two weeks notice because I
think that's what you're supposed to do
uh but there's really no Playbook uh for
when you haven't started yet and I
remember just like starting to smile and
look at me and say you know what all the
partners are making bets on if you
started how long you would actually stay
for and so this is totally what you
should do and you should feel
comfortable doing it but keep in mind
like we were just graduating University
so you know grand scheme of things we
had fundraising secured uh we were you
know able to live off of ramen noodles
and eggs and that was that was okay uh
for for a while and it was just a ton of
fun moving and breaking things I think
the younger you are the less risk you
have for others around you and I think
as we've grown the business you know we
have over a thousand people and I now
have to consider every single one of
them in the decisions that I make but at
the time it was really just myself and a
couple people and so it made it super
easy when you didn't have a mortgage you
didn't have like all this overhead there
there weren't like tuition there wasn't
tuition to pay so I I think the younger
you are the more competitive Advantage
you innately have to make financially
daring decisions whereas later on in
life it's a lot harder because it's more
at stake so I think the sooner you can
get into entrepreneurship I think that's
why you see so many brilliant young
people today uh do really crazy
Innovative things is because they're
just crazy enough to and do it and
there's there's not these life
encumbrances that they may hold them
back um and so I think you need to make
smart calculated moves and at the time
we we didn't know what the reward was we
just were taking the risk but we were
fully prepared to see it through outside
of your customers is there one business
rule that you operate by no matter what
oh that's a great question yeah I my
barber back in the day used to tell me
that the customer's always right and so
when I told him to cut a little bit more
off the top he would be like okay but
customer's always right so so I think
that's a cardinal rule but uh sometimes
maybe not um one thing that I've gotten
very comfortable with as of late and
that I think has been really clear is
that there are really three three groups
of people that will help your business
get to where it needs to be and I think
that people's ability to move between
each of those curves is what defines how
big their business can get and so the
first uh the first stage is really
agents of chaos everyone knows this it's
like one to 10 person teams building and
and just breaking things and just
building a lot of value in a chaotic
environment you then bring in that one
or two person team member that will help
drive a little bit more sanity and start
to try to create processes whether
that's a Google form using a sauna
something to just create structure
meeting minutes calendar invites um and
then you have people that really like
live and thrive in that environment they
document everything they store it away
they title it nicely and the Agents of
chaos aren't always the people that love
to work in that like really rigid
structured environment and you know some
companies hold on to people that are
agents of chaos for a while because they
really like that rapid build and they
associate rapid Equity value creation
and building a business with those
people and they don't make that
transition ultimately to where they need
to be and I think one thing that we had
to get comfortable with as our business
grew at over 300% a year for the past
six seven years is that things change
quickly and we need to make sure that
we're bringing on the people that can
help us get to that next level that
makes sense so speaking of next levels
talk to me about what's ahead for you
anything in 2024 that's new and exciting
you can tell me about
it it's you know more more of the same
we want to be in more markets faster we
want to leverage our asset light model
to help more uh Merchants Electrify
their their volume um we're on this tear
where we want to get to a billion a
revenue as a business and so that's the
next big milestone for us how are you
going to do that more of the same just
more markets faster working with bigger
better brands that that we're you know
we're already fortunate to to work with
a lot of and uh just hopefully keeping
uh doing good work and staying staying
kind of anchored on our values excellent
and one last question for you what would
would you like your legacy to be that's
that's a very good question I I think uh
it's interesting to think about that at
at my age right now I I think hopefully
there's a couple more impact areas we
can have outside of goalt but within
goalt we'd like to be known as uh change
makers that really challenge a status
quo in an industry that has literally
not changed for for decades and prove
that it can be done despite it being a
multi-trillion dollar space excellent
well thank you so much Mark I appreciate
you being here thanks for having
me
[Music]
h